STEPHANIE WENDELIN: So today
I'm really excited because we
have two very special guests.
The first has been on YouTube
for about five years, which
is like a really long
time in YouTube history.
So you're like, actually, one
of our original rock stars.
Kandee Johnson, so come
on to the stage Kandee.
So Kandee's channel is
pretty easy to remember.
It's youtube.com/kandeejohnson.
And you now have almost
two million subscribers.
You've been on the platform
for a while, you're a mom,
you're kind of like this
modern Renaissance woman.
KANDEE JOHNSON: Thanks.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
Why do we just
take a quick peek at
one of Kandee's videos,
so you can see what the
content looks like on YouTube.
[MUSIC PLAYING] _ _ _ _ _ _
_ _ _ _ _ _
KANDEE JOHNSON: Hi guys.
It's Kandee, and I haven't
done a tag video in so long.
So this is going
to be so much fun.
So I'm going to be
doing the TMI tag.
And if you don't
know, TMI stands
for "too much information."
So you're going to learn a
little too much information
about myself.
And I was tagged by Sammi,
from beautycrush, who I love.
So thank you for
tagging me Sammi.
OK, so let's get started.
The first question is,
what are you wearing?
I'm wearing my
"What's Sup?" shirt.
And you can't see it, but like,
I'm wearing my boyfriend jeans,
and--
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
So you guys get it,
it's really fun, the TMI tag is
kind of blowing up right now,
which is kind of cool.
But Kandee, how did you
get started on Youtube?
Tell us a little bit about
that, and your channel,
and your message.
KANDEE JOHNSON:
Well I got started
because one of my
friends, he actually
showed me a video of Lauren
Luke in the UK, panacea81.
And I saw her video,
and the only thing
I had noticed for
YouTube before was like,
oh that's where you go when you
see like a cat water skiing,
or like you see some
dumb funny video.
And I thought it
was genius, I was
like, she's doing
a makeup-- she's
using YouTube to do a tutorial?
Like I was blown away.
And I just fell in love
with her, because I'm like,
I feel like I'm her best friend,
and she doesn't know it yet.
And I was like, I could do this.
I was a makeup artist before,
like in TV, and movies,
and all that stuff.
And I had moved
away from LA, which
I thought was
horrible at the time.
I was like, I'm moving
away from my dream,
like this is so awful.
And when I was there, my
friend showed me the video,
and he's like, this is--
you can still teach.
You can still feel creative.
And so I was like, I
will share all my tips
that I know as a makeup artist.
And my first video
you don't even see me,
and I had a cold, so it
doesn't even sound like me.
And I--
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: Do you
remember what a video was?
KANDEE JOHNSON:It was how to
clean your makeup brushes.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
I've seen that video.
I use that, by the way.
The olive oil--
KANDEE JOHNSON: It works.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:Yeah
you use olive oil--
KANDEE JOHNSON: It
conditions your bristles--
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
Yeah, so I use that trip.
That tip that you gave.
KANDEE JOHNSON: Yay.
I'm kind of honored.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:Yeah, it's
amazing because if you look
at your content now,
it has evolved so much.
KANDEE JOHNSON:Oh my gosh, I
didn't even know how you got
things onto YouTube.
I YouTubed how to YouTube.
I would type into
YouTube, I'm like,
"how to get things from your
camera on your computer."
I didn't even know how to word
it right in the search bar.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
It's amazing, yeah.
KANDEE JOHNSON: I learned how
to edit on YouTube, I'm like,
"how to make it words
on your picture video."
Like it was so ridiculous.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
Were you always though,
into makeup, and kind
of the beauty space?
I know that you also modeled,
and you did celebrity makeup.
KANDEE JOHNSON: Oh yeah,
I've always loved beauty,
and the thing is, people would
always be in my chair working.
And it would always
be the everyday woman
that would be sitting
there, or even celebrities
would be like, how did
you learn how to do this?
How come I never learned this?
My mother taught me, I
wish you could teach me.
Wish you would come
to my makeup everyday.
And then when I came
[? up with YouTube ?] I'm like,
I can kind of be in your
bathroom everyday with you
when you do your
makeup, and teaching
stuff that you don't learn.
You don't learn-- I
went to beauty school,
and I didn't learn
how to do makeup.
So--
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: And I think
it's funny because-- I actually
got married a couple years
ago-- and when I was looking
for my looks, what I was
going to go down the aisle--
KANDEE JOHNSON: Your
princess moment--
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
Might look, I actually
used a video from your channel.
KANDEE JOHNSON: You did?
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:It was the
Taylor Swift, "Love Story."
KANDEE JOHNSON:It's
so beautiful!
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: Yes,
so I took the video,
I sent it to my makeup
artist for the wedding,
and I was like, can you do this?
I bought all the products,
every single product.
She ended up
referencing the video,
and she's like I learned
stuff from the video.
And then she emailed
me and was like,
how can I be a YouTube star?
And I was like, OK,
that's another--
KANDEE JOHNSON:I'm like,
are you ready for that,
because there's more
than just being "funzey."
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:So
OK, going way, way back,
when you were doing
celebrity makeup,
do you have any juicy stories?
Who did you work with?
I think I saw the worked
with Janice Dickinson.
KANDEE JOHNSON:
She was the last,
because then I tapered
off, because YouTube
took over my life.
And then I had no
time to do that.
So I think Janice Dickinson, and
Conan O'Brien were the last two
that I did while I was
still doing YouTube.
So it was really--
that was weird
because I was so used
to editing, and things,
and then to still
do a job, and then I
couldn't post pictures
about it, because you
can't show that stuff.
So that was really weird.
KANDEE JOHNSON:So you
kind of realized, wow,
I have this budding business.
And now you're kind of like a
celebrity in your own right.
Which I think is
really exciting.
Do you get recognized?
Like when you're
out on the street?
KANDEE JOHNSON:Yeah,
and it's really weird,
because like I don't feel
like I'm a celebrity at all,
so it's so weird.
Because at first, when
somebody would come up
and they'd be
like, oh hi Kandee,
and I'd be like, oh my gosh,
I don't know your name.
Do I know you from work?
School?
My brain would just be going
a million miles an hour--
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
You're kind of panicking--
KANDEE JOHNSON: And
they would just kind of
stand there like, hi Kandee.
And I'm like, hi.
I don't know what to say now.
And then they'd be like,
I watch you on YouTube.
And I was like, (SIGHS) I don't
need to know your name right
this second, hooray.
But it's still--
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:It's
still wacky, right?
KANDEE JOHNSON:It's still weird.
I was not popular
in high school,
so that anybody knows me
I'm like, you know my name?
Oh my gosh, you know my name.
Oh, my goodness.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: Would
you say you were shy?
A shyer person before
you came onto YouTube?
KANDEE JOHNSON: I was
super shy in high school,
like I didn't talk, ever.
I would just sit and
eat lunch by myself,
because I was too scared
people would make fun of me,
I'm like, if I say
hello, they will
make fun of how I say hello, so
I'll just eat with my teacher.
I was so not cool in
high school, at all.
I had things to say, but
I was so terrified people
would make fun of me.
I'm like, I'll just keep
every idea I have inside.
And no one will make
fun of me that way.
So it's so weird now.
It just feels so crazy to me,
like anybody would like me,
because you felt so
unlikable before.
I'm like, you really like me?
You really watch my videos?
Oh my gosh.
I get so excited.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
It's so cool.
I was listening,
actually, to this podcast.
It was talking about people
that changed your life.
I think what's really
interesting about YouTube
is that you hear from your
fans all the time, how
you changed their life.
And hearing from
someone who maybe
was typically shy
in high school,
and now has this whole
following on YouTube,
I think that's a really
inspirational story.
KANDEE JOHNSON:I hope
it inspires them.
It makes them feel like it's OK.
It's OK if you're
terrified to say any words.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: But
everybody also has trolls.
Which is another
thing about YouTube.
So how do you deal with some of
the, the naysaying, and the--
KANDEE JOHNSON: It was
hard because at first,
I had dealt with girls
being mean to me,
and saying mean things to
me in school, and stuff.
But never like YouTube.
I've been told everything, my
eyes are ugly, my nose is ugly.
I look like a man.
The sound of my voice is
annoying, I should kill myself.
I've just been told everything.
Like, oh your next video
should be you killing yourself.
I just wasted 10
minutes of my life.
I'm like, well you just wasted
30 more typing me this comment.
I'm like, "whaaaa," this
is is so irritating.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
And I guess you
just kind of have to learn
how to filter it out, and--
KANDEE JOHNSON:
Well, and then you
learn not everybody's
mentally sound.
They're just sitting
behind a keyboard.
I learned don't ever respond.
And don't ever type
back, well you're
not putting your
face on YouTube,
you ugly person
behind your computer.
I would never reply,
never respond.
I will respond nicely.
So this one girl wrote me this
thing, you look like a man,
you ratchet face, blah blah.
She just went on, and on,
just tearing me apart.
And so I clicked on her profile
picture, and I was like,
oh she's really pretty.
And so I just wrote back, I'm
like, you are so beautiful.
It's so sad that you just
let such ugly words come out
your mouth, because
I would never
see something like that to you.
The girl totally did a 180.
She was like, I'm so sorry, I
was having the worst day ever.
And I was like, I hope
your day feels better,
and I hope if you have another
bad day, that you choose
to make somebody else feel
better, because in turn, it
will help your day feel better.
You just made yourself
feel uglier on the inside.
And you just totally
ruined my night
by saying all that junk to me.
And then by the end, I was like,
I send you a bunch of hugs,
you know, I hope
you feel better.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
That's kind of
like a hallmark of
your channel too.
KANDEE JOHNSON: My hugs.
My virtual hugs.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
You're very inspiring,
you're always about making
someone's day better.
KANDEE JOHNSON:And she turned
around to me, she's like,
I love you, and I send you hugs.
I'm like, from
ratchet face to love.
This is crazy.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: That's
a touching moment, where
you realize that you
actually have an impact,
and someone changed
the way that way--
KANDEE JOHNSON: And it
wasn't like, I am ugly.
I am a ratchet
face, or whatever.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: Do you
have a favorite fan moment?
Or one thing that
really touched you?
KANDEE JOHNSON: Oh my gosh.
It was probably the first
girl that ever sent me
an email that was like-- and
it was shortly after I started.
And she sent me an
email, and it makes
me want to cry every
time I tell the story.
But she sent me an
email, and she's
like, I was going
to commit suicide,
and I wanted to look pretty
when people discovered me.
And just that thought
alone was like, ah,
my heart just broke for her.
And she said, "I typed in pretty
makeup, and for some reason
your video was the top that
came up on my search at Google."
And I was just like,
oh my goodness,
and she said, "I want you
to know that it's like,
seven hours later, and I
just watched your video
straight through, and
just seeing your story,
and seeing what
you've been through,
and your outlook and attitude,"
she said, "I'm still alive.
And you gave me
hope to keep going."
And I was like, this
is where people say,
oh beauty's so superficial,
bunch of lipstick, and mascara.
And my [INAUDIBLE]
thing is that I
feel that makeup
is an invitation
for your inner
confidence to come out.
It's nothing about this outside.
It's what it does to your heart
that makes a woman that, maybe
she's been beaten,
abused, or been
told she's ugly, or horrible.
And for her to feel beautiful,
she's going to walk different.
She's going to talk different.
She's going to act differently.
It doesn't matter
how many layers,
or not layers of mascara
or blush she has on.
It's about what she feels like.
And that is what--
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
That's what you guys do.
That's the amazing thing about
the beauty category on YouTube,
and I'm going to invite
Meg up too, because I think
she probably has
similar moments.
And also, I know that you
probably have inspired her,
as well.
I know that you're a fan.
And so why don't we actually
open the conversation
up a little bit more.
We'll invite Meg, whose
channel is ciaoobelllaxo.
She's been on YouTube
also for about four years?
Five years.
She has about
500,000 subscribers,
also huge on the platform.
So we'll show a quick
clip, and you can come up,
and we'll continue
the conversation.
MEGAN KROH:Hey guys.
Today, I'm doing a
get ready with me.
This has been long awaited
for, and finally getting around
to do it.
So you guys can see, how I
do my foundation, everything.
I'm showing all of my makeup.
And I didn't show my hair,
because this was just
a super simple hairstyle that
I did today with my sockbun.
A hair tutorial, if
you have not seen that,
I'll link it down below.
And also I'm going to
show my outfit for today.
So I hope you guys
enjoy, and keep
watching if you want to see
how I did my makeup today.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: Tell us a
little bit about your channel
too, and how you got started.
MEGAN KROH: I got started
when I was in high school.
I was going into my junior year,
and beauty was never really
anything I thought about.
I wasn't really that
talented with makeup.
I liked applying makeup,
and things like that.
But actually, it's
so funny that you
mention Lauren Luke, because
she was the first person that I
saw.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: I think
she's the first person.
She really kind of
started this whole thing.
And it's been an inspiration I
think for so many beauty gurus
too, and I know some
people hate that word.
MEGAN KROH: Yeah, I do.
KANDEE JOHNSON: I know,
the word "guru" just
makes me want to vomit.
I'm like, bleh, can we
please stop using it,
and make up a new word?
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:But I
think everybody's seen Lauren,
so that's really cool.
And then you've been
doing it since then?
MEGAN KROH: M-hm, yeah.
I think I looked up some prom
makeup, or something like that.
And she was the first
person that I saw.
And I just got
addicted to her videos.
And I was like you know what?
I think I'm going to do this.
I'm going to put
myself out there.
And I didn't really have that
many friends in high school.
And I felt like
I couldn't really
connect with that many people.
So YouTube is the way to go.
That's what I did.
Made my first video.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: And
that's another thing
cool about the platform,
is I feel like I meet fans,
and I meet YouTubers
all the time
who are saying like, I
feel like I know you.
They're saying, I feel
like you're my best friend.
Or I have a million best
friends on my channel.
KANDEE JOHNSON: And you're
talking right in the camera,
so it feels like you're directly
talking to the person too.
So I feel like that when I
meet other YouTubers, I'm like,
you're not in my
phone, or [INAUDIBLE],
you're really here,
it's so weird.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: So
how do you guys-- both
have been on the platform
for a little while.
How do you continue
to find inspiration?
Like where you go
when you're looking
for the topic for
your next video?
Is it fan sourced, is it
a combination of things?
Are you looking at trends?
MEGAN KROH: I go to
Pinterest sometimes.
I love Pinterest.
I have an addiction.
But I don't know,
sometimes if I'm
looking to do a new makeup
look, or something, or maybe
an outfit of the day,
whatever season it is,
I'll go to Pinterest, and look
at fashion, or makeup trends,
or something like that.
I like the Pinterest.
So that's one thing that I do.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: Do you ever
respond to the fan requests,
"Can we do this? "
KANDEE JOHNSON: That's how I
started my first few videos,
because I'd, "Comment below
on what you want to see."
Or I'd give them
the option, like do
you want to see Kim Kardashian?
Do you want to see Kat Von D?
You want to see who?
And then I would just see
whoever commented the most,
and that's where it feels
like a relationship.
Where I'm like, tell me
what you want to see?
You feel like you're
like, "I'm your performer,
just show me what
you want me to do. "
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: Exactly.
You do the Groucho Marx thing.
You want to see Groucho Marx?
KANDEE JOHNSON: Yeah,
I'll do that too.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
And another thing
that I guess for me is kind
of a point of interest, is
do you look at your data on
the back end from your YouTube
Analytics perspective, and
see what's performing well,
and kind of tweak
the kind of content
that you make based on that?
Do you ever look at
your-- because that's
the kind of stuff I geek out on.
I look at videos,
and I'm like, oh
where was the drop off point?
Or where do people
really show interest?
You're using a lot
of that backup stuff?
KANDEE JOHNSON: Well I
think it's dangerous,
because it makes
you-- like at first,
I would get really
addicted to stat checking,
like I would check
like three times a day.
I'd be like, how
views did I get now?
What about lunchtime?
Is it better at nighttime?
I would just like,
freak out about it.
And I was like, stop it.
Just make stuff, and then
stop looking at your numbers,
or you're going to just make
yourself into a crazy person.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
Yeah, exactly.
MEGAN KROH: I think it
has its ups and downs.
It can be good for
you, but then it
could also be bad if
you do it constantly.
I don't do it all
that often, but if I
feel like I'm not feeling
very motivated, or I do
need to look at my
statistics, to see OK,
what video did they really like?
What can I do again that will--
KANDEE JOHNSON: Or it will
be the weirdest video too.
Like some of my
most popular ones,
are videos I don't like,
or wasn't going to upload.
And I was like, I have nothing
else, I'll just edit this.
And then it became
like, the most popular.
And I'm like, really?
Ugh.
Like that's what's
popular, great.
The thing I edit for
like days, I'm like,
this is going to wow everyone.
And then, they're like,
no we like crappy one
with the bad lighting, and it's
ugly and you look [INAUDIBLE].
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
It's funny what
fans gravitate to for sure.
KANDEE JOHNSON: It's so weird.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: And
to speak to that point
about, all the work
that goes into it,
I remember a couple
years back we
were working on something
together for L'Oreal.
And we talked on the phone
one day, and you're like,
I was a up all-- I pulled an
all nighter, I was doing--
and I think sometimes people
just neglect to think about all
of the work that goes into the
production of your channels.
Because you're doing it all.
You're doing the shooting,
the editing, the planning,
the uploading, the megatagging,
like all that stuff.
KANDEE JOHNSON: And I
think people think like,
oh just film a little video
and throw it up in 45 minutes,
and that's all.
And you're like oh my gosh.
Like I edit for days.
It's like very long.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
It's a labor of love.
KANDEE JOHNSON: And uploading
isn't just an upload.
It's so stressful.
I'm like, I've got to
get the tags right.
And the description
has to [INAUDIBLE]
What am I going to call it?
MEGAN KROH: You're not even
done after you've edited.
You still got to edit
when it's uploaded.
KANDEE JOHNSON: And
then your thumbnail
has to shoot fireworks out of
people's eyeballs, it's just
like, ugh, so much stuff.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
So how would you
describe like a typical day?
Like when you get up,
and you're like, OK.
I'm going to plan a video
today, or I'm going to shoot.
Like what goes into the process?
It's probably hard
to boil it down.
KANDEE JOHNSON: It's hard.
It's hard, because
then like, you
don't have a dedicated studio.
So like, I have to like,
haul all my lights down,
and put them in my bedroom.
And then I have to like, I can
only film from certain hours,
because then the sun's
going to come in,
and it's going to make
it look super ugly.
So I have like, hurry
and film before the sun
starts-- it's so stressful.
MEGAN KROH: It is
really stressful.
I do the same thing, because
where I film is my bedroom too.
So it's like, I
have my workspace
with my computer, my vanity
where I do my makeup, and then
my bed.
And it's just a cluttered mess.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: And you
have to make sure everything
looks right, and you have to
light it, and you have to--
KANDEE JOHNSON: And then
you're running back and forth,
because you're your own camera
person, and lighting person.
So I like, put a stuffed
animal on my chair,
run around the
camera, am I in focus,
going back to the
stuffed animal,
move the stuffed animal, oh
now I moved that, now I'm not
where the stuffed animal
was, I'm not focused.
Like it's just so
frustrating some days.
I'm like, (CRYING).
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
So how long would you
say, if you had to
boil, how long would you
say a typical video takes
you from start to finish?
From the moment you
shoot, to uploading?
Probably tons of hours, right?
MEGAN KROH: I think it depends
on the video, probably.
Tutorials, I feel
take up the most time.
But other like short
videos, things like tags--
KANDEE JOHNSON: A
tag video is so easy.
MEGAN KROH: Yeah,
they're pretty easy.
KANDEE JOHNSON: It's
like a vacation day.
But a tutorial's
like, oh my gosh,
now I got to go and run
around and zoom the camera.
And now I'm going to zoom,
and go back and run around.
Now I've got to show my mascara.
It's like so stressful.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
And then you probably,
a lot of times you're filming
the voiceovers separately.
So then you have to go back
and look, after you've edited,
and film the voiceover.
So I just wanted to
make sure that we
covered all that
technical stuff.
Because I think it's
really cool that you guys
are pretty much self-taught.
Did you ever take Photoshop
classes, or Final Cut classes?
You just kind of learned edit?
KANDEE JOHNSON:I
YouTubed everything--
MEGAN KROH:I googled--
KANDEE JOHNSON: I went
to YouTube university.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
That's so funny.
Do you have-- before we get into
the fun stuff, which is really
going to be all about
makeup, because I want
to talk to you guys about
trends, and what's coming,
do you have any advice for
people out there who might want
to start a channel, whether
it's beauty, or not?
KANDEE JOHNSON: I
think always, the rule
should always be
talk like you're
talking to your friend,
brother, sister,
somebody so it's natural.
I think a lot of
people, sometimes they
feel like they have
to get into character,
or a different
something, and that's not
what YouTube is meant for.
YouTube is meant to be like,
feel like they're your friend.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
Make it feel intimate.
KANDEE JOHNSON: And don't
care about the haters,
because every single person
I know on YouTube gets
told they're ugly, they
should kill themselves,
people stalking them, all
kinds of crazy things.
So just ignore it, know
that everybody gets it.
They're not just picking on you.
They say everyone's ugly.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
Any advice from you?
MEGAN KROH: I would say I agree.
I think you need to be yourself,
because I feel like when anyone
wants to start a channel,
they get inspiration
from other YouTubers.
And they kind of want
to do videos like them,
and not necessarily
be like them,
but be yourself, and
show your character.
Show your talent, and I
think just be yourself.
Plain and simple.
I tell everyone that.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
Probably stick with it too,
because I think a
lot of people think
they're going to get
onto the platform,
and immediately build a fan
base, and it's going to be--
KANDEE JOHNSON: Well it takes
longer a now, because back when
I started, there was very few
of us in the beauty category,
like at all.
And we would all be
on the popular page.
We would just watch and
look for each other.
And it's funny because
I'd be at another panel,
and I'd be talking to Ellen
and Blair, and they'd be like,
well we would look
and see when Kandee
said she was going to upload.
If she was going
to upload, we were
going to wait on our video.
And I was like, you did?
You thought I was
that important you
were going to move your video?
I was kind of honored.
But it was so funny, because it
was so-- it's not competitive
then.
And now there's like, hundreds
of thousands of people.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
It's saturated.
KANDEE JOHNSON: So all day
long, I get girls like,
I know everybody hates
these, but will you
check my channel out?
And I always tell them
like, don't do this.
People are going to hate
you right off the bat.
Go to your friends.
Go to your Facebook.
Your Twitter.
That's how--
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
Start grassroots.
KANDEE JOHNSON: I never went
on somebody's video, and like,
hey, but go check out mine.
Don't steal somebody's
thunder on their page.
MEGAN KROH: All those comments
get spammed all automatically,
anyway.
KANDEE JOHNSON: And then
people don't like you.
They're never going to go
watch your video if they
think you're annoying already.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
You kind of have
to build your street
cred first, right?
KANDEE JOHNSON: Yes.
You got to get your
"gangster cred."
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: Exactly.
"Gangster cred."
Cool.
OK, so that's the business side
of things, and the inspiration,
and the life as
a YouTuber stuff.
But we also want to talk about
how do we look as good as you?
How do we do our makeup right?
KANDEE JOHNSON: Lots of
pounds and pounds of makeup.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: Do
you wear makeup every day?
Would you say that you do?
MEGAN KROH: No.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: Does it
feel good to have an off day?
I know Saturday and Sunday
rolls around for a lot of women,
and they're like, (SIGHS).
OK, my skin can breathe.
KANDEE JOHNSON: Most
days are my off days.
Like the days I do videos are
my only makeup days, really.
Yeah
MEGAN KROH: Pretty much.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
On a normal morning,
if you're going to
go out, how long
would you say your
makeup routine takes?
KANDEE JOHNSON: Like on a normal
day that I that I don't wear--
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
Or if you're going
to go, maybe if you're not
filming, but you're going out.
Like a normal routine.
Maybe not filming,
because that's
going to be a different--
KANDEE JOHNSON: This took
me half an hour today.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: I guess
it depends on the look.
I guess what I'm
getting to is like,
for a career woman,
or someone who
is getting ready in the
morning, maybe is in a hurry--
KANDEE JOHNSON: Ten,
fifteen minutes?
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: Yes, is
that a normal amount of time?
So it shouldn't
take like two hours?
KANDEE JOHNSON: No, no.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: Do
you have any golden rules
that you live by?
Kind of steps that
you would never skip?
MEGAN KROH: Concealer.
Oh gosh, it's a savior.
Yeah It's amazing.
KANDEE JOHNSON: And concealer
on your eyelids with eyeshadow,
or powder, then your eye shadow.
Never just put eye shadow
on your naked lids,
or even with the cream.
You need to dry it off
first with the powder.
That would be my--
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: Love it.
KANDEE JOHNSON: Take
that [INAUDIBLE].
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: I'm like
taking mental notes right now.
And I guess, do you have
any essential products?
Do you have ones
that you swear by?
It doesn't have to
be a brand, per say,
it could just be-- we
just heard concealer.
That is a huge trick.
I didn't learn about the
concealer on the eyelid
until after I took a class
at Sephora, like last week.
KANDEE JOHNSON: What?
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: Not kidding.
(GASPS)
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
Yeah because they
do these free classes at
Sephora, you could sign up.
And I took a flawless
foundation class,
and they were like,
here's a tip for you.
And I was like oh, OK.
That makes sense.
Like makeup artists have
been doing that for years,
like you don't need a primer.
Just put a concealer,
and a powder on.
And then go to town.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: So anything
that you couldn't live without?
KANDEE JOHNSON: I would go with
concealer, and black eyeliner.
MEGAN KROH: I would say
concealer, and mascara.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: I think
my favorite product right now
is one that I just
got from Sephora.
It's the Urban Decay spray.
KANDEE JOHNSON: Oh
the all night spray?
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: Yeah.
It like keeps your
foundation on your face.
MEGAN KROH: I would say
that's an essential too.
KANDEE JOHNSON:
There's another one
is even stronger
that will water--
it could rain on your face.
And it won't come off.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
That's amazing.
How do you guys do that stuff?
When I got my makeup
done for my wedding,
and anyone who's I married
and had their makeup done,
I just was like, how
is this even possible?
I got up at like 6:00 AM,
she did my makeup at 7:00.
The wedding was at 9:30.
I went to Jazz
Fest all day long,
and then I had my reception,
and my face was just, like, on.
KANDEE JOHNSON: If you apply
it carefully, it will last.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: But I
think the other thing is
for a lot of us,
you don't grow up
learning all those tricks
and tips from your mom.
Is there hope for
the women out there?
Do you think it takes
an artist's touch to--
KANDEE JOHNSON: No.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: Do you
think it's accessible--
KANDEE JOHNSON: I'm impressed
when I see young girls now.
I'll see them somewhere,
I'm like, oh my gosh.
Your makeup is amazing.
I couldn't do that when--
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: They're
learning from you guys.
KANDEE JOHNSON: --I
was fifteen years old.
It's amazing.
Because these weren't,
the tricks weren't around,
and to know how to
do it wasn't around.
And so now that
everybody is sharing it,
I think it's awesome.
I don't think my makeup artist
friends were very happy.
They're like, why
are we going to work?
You're giving away
all my tricks.
I'm like, you want the world
ugly, so you make a dollar.
Like that's not nice.
Like just share.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: Do
you guys have your go
to resources for your
beauty news, and stuff?
Like I'm a dedicated
"Allure" reader,
and I know that like a
lot of people go to--
KANDEE JOHNSON: "Allure"
is about the beauty.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: Any
other kind of, [INAUDIBLE]
the other thing
that I really like
is, "People" has a
style watch magazine.
And they have the like,
splurge here, save here.
KANDEE JOHNSON:
Those are always fun.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
Do you guys have
splurge versus drugstore
buys that you love or hate?
Or what do you skimp
on versus spend on?
KANDEE JOHNSON: I think
you can skimp on mascaras
if you have a good primer.
Don't skimp on
foundation or concealer.
That's where you want to invest
in the priming of the canvas,
and then you can cheap
up the decoration.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: That's
actually a really good point
that no one really
teaches you either,
make sure that you
moisturize, and then prime,
and then put your foundation on.
I didn't even know primer
was a product until recently.
It's like from watching you
guys, I'm like oh great idea.
KANDEE JOHNSON: And
make sure it doesn't
have dimethicone or silicone,
because it can actually
enlarge your pores.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: I learned
that at the Sephora last week.
They said use a water-based one.
That Smashbox one.
KANDEE JOHNSON: Because
then they're like hey,
it'll stretch of out your
pores, and then you'll
have to buy primer for life.
It's like they hook you.
It's like horrible, like a drug
for your pores or something.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: Exactly.
Oh my gosh.
So let's talk about
trends, like what we think
is going to be big this year.
I just learned too that the
Pantone Color of the Year
is orchid.
It's actually very similar
to your hair color.
[INAUDIBLE] darker.
KANDEE JOHNSON:
The tube said pink.
It's not pink.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: So what do
you think is going to be big
this year based on
what you've seen?
I've heard some people
say the tribal stick
ons for nails, which
I haven't seen.
KANDEE JOHNSON: Wait, didn't
we get rid of tribal tattoos?
(MUMBLES)
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: What do
you really into right now?
MEGAN KROH: I love
the color lilac.
I'm obsessed with pastel colors.
I think they're coming
back for spring.
I've seen it in stores,
but I love pastel colors.
They just make me happy.
KANDEE JOHNSON: They're
soft [INAUDIBLE].
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
You have a nice palette
of pastel on today.
MEGAN KROH: Like
I'm sick already.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: And
today's a nicer day.
KANDEE JOHNSON: We were
totally in [INAUDIBLE].
In sync.
So pastels, do you have any--
KANDEE JOHNSON: I think it's
hard, because trends always
seem to circulate back around.
I think it's hard to
say a makeup trend,
because some I'm like,
I'm not [INAUDIBLE],
I don't care what editor
says well that's cool.
That is not wearable.
Like the Pantone Color.
That's cool, but nobody's going
to go around in that lipstick.
They're just--
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: That's
an intense color right there.
KANDEE JOHNSON: No one's
wearing that eyeshadow.
So I think a smoky eye
is always so pretty.
And then just like
a winged liner.
It's timeless.
You can look at it on
Marilyn Monroe in the '50s,
and she would look
just as amazing today.
If you do too many trends, then
you're going to look like--
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
Go classic, maybe
keep the trends to a minimum.
KANDEE JOHNSON: I think
matte lipcolor is fun.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: Do
one trend at a time.
KANDEE JOHNSON: Yeah,
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: I love that.
So speaking of like, sometimes
I know that you guys,
brands will push a trend too.
So do you guys
ever get approached
by brands who are asking
you to do work with them,
and it's really not a product
that you would endorse?
How do you balance
your authenticity
with some of the brand
asks that come out?
KANDEE JOHNSON: I think that's
the hard part about YouTube,
is I think a lot of
young YouTube girls
get into YouTube for
the wrong reason.
I started because I wanted to
share my tips to help people.
I didn't start
YouTube to help me,
or to get YouTube famous
for things like that.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: You
probably didn't even
know that there
was such a thing.
KANDEE JOHNSON: I didn't know
that could be a business.
I just thought it
would be fun to do it.
And I think that is probably
one of the one downfalls,
it disappoints me a
little bit in that part--
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
The commercialization?
KANDEE JOHNSON: Because your
integrity needs to matter more.
I mean, people
offer you $1 all day
long to talk about
something, but it
has to be something you like.
And I just think a
lot of people need
a little bit of
coaching in that area.
Like don't do this to
buy a new Chanel bag,
because you just made
a bunch of money,
like do it to help people.
And put your efforts in
a different area, what
you value in different
areas, I think.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: I
think that's the thing,
because I work on
the brand side.
Like I said, I help kind
of arrange these marriages.
But for me it really
is about the marriage,
like making sure
it's the right fit
and making sure that
the brand is aligned,
and ensuring too that you guys
have the creative control,
and that it still
feels like your voice.
Do you ever have to say no?
Or have there been situations
where it's been a perfect fit,
and you've been really
happy with the work
that you've done with
the brand, in cases
where you have said yes?
KANDEE JOHNSON: I think I say no
more than I would ever say yes.
Because if you said
yes to all the deals,
your channel would look like
a commercial for everything.
And I think that's going to
be a problem in [INAUDIBLE].
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: You have
to protect your own brand too,
right.
KANDEE JOHNSON:
And a lot of times
it's hard, because I get so
excited about makeup stuff,
I just love it.
And so when I've
talked about things,
people assume that
I paid, and I was
like you're assuming I get
paid because everybody else is
doing stinking paid staff.
And I just think
this is awesome,
and I'm talking about it, and
now you guys think I'm paid.
That irritates me to no end.
I'm like, no, I just
love it, I bought it,
I'll show you the
sticking receipt.
It just makes me so angry.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: It
really has become, I think,
kind of a little bit
of a cluttered market,
and knowing that you're very
careful with the endorsements
that you do you
choose to go with,
and that it is about like
a natural connection,
I think is really important
probably to your fans.
They know that you're
not going to hawk so--
KANDEE JOHNSON:
Something to them.
Or there is a group
of YouTubers talking.
They were all
talking about, they
were in a successful so
and so, blah, blah, blah,
all these things.
And after about 45
minutes of listening to it
as I was cleaning up my
stuff, I just went over.
I like, you know what?
Why did you guys start YouTube?
Why?
And some of them
just openly admitted,
they're like, I did it so
I could get free stuff.
And I was like, (SIGHS).
I have nothing to tell you.
That is the worst
reason to start YouTube.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: It's
not for the endgame.
KANDEE JOHNSON: Yeah
you should be almost
like I'm doing it to
entertain, to educate,
to do something else.
Not because, "I'm
going to be famous,
and I want to have a
designer bag, and--"
that's not the reason.
That shouldn't be your reason
why you started YouTube.
KANDEE JOHNSON: Everybody
wants to be famous.
OK so two more questions.
The first one is, if
I weren't on YouTube,
I would be doing blank.
KANDEE JOHNSON: If
I wasn't on YouTube,
I'd still probably be
hustling, doing makeup.
Trying to get makeup
jobs, and then not getting
a job for three weeks, and
then five requests for one day,
and just be really good
at saving my money,
because I wouldn't know when
I was going to work next.
KANDEE JOHNSON: I'd agree.
I actually do hair and
makeup on the side,
because I have my
cosmetology license now,
so that's what I would be doing,
but literally my entire life
is YouTube, so.
But I would still be
doing makeup and hair.
Because that's just what I love.
I wouldn't pick anything else.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: OK and
the last one's a fun one too.
If you were going on
"Survivor" and you
could take one item with
you, what would you take?
We talked about razors,
we'll just like,
because apparently
you go on "Survivor"
and the women all
have shaved armpits--
KANDEE JOHNSON: And legs--
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
--the whole time.
KANDEE JOHNSON:
How do you do that?
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: I
thought this was "Survivor."
KANDEE JOHNSON: You're supposed
to have a shell, and a tree
branch.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
What's going on here?
Anyway--
KANDEE JOHNSON: You
took a shower you liar.
I'd go with concealer.
MEGAN KROH: I would
say the same thing.
I was totally going
to say the same thing.
Because, I don't know.
Yeah
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
I just learned
how to use a concealer brush,
you guys are probably thinking,
she's such a nube.
Because I went to Sephora
for this class, and it
was the flawless
foundation class.
And they had like
these special--
KANDEE JOHNSON: Did they not
give you the beauty blender
sponge?
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: They didn't.
They gave me the--
KANDEE JOHNSON: What?
They're fired.
Is that what I need to get?
OK I need the flawless face.
The thing that
looks like a cone?
KANDEE JOHNSON:
The pink egg thing.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
It's a ball, OK.
MEGAN KROH: With a tip on it.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
It's what it looks like.
KANDEE JOHNSON: And make
sure you use it wet.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: OK.
KANDEE JOHNSON: Damp.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: Interesting.
KANDEE JOHNSON: You
will look airbrushed.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
Good to know.
OK, that's what I need.
Especially with these lights.
Cool.
All right, so we've got it.
Does anybody have questions?
We're going to open it up for
like 15 minutes of questions.
This is the time.
Flawless foundation questions,
how to get started on YouTube.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Kandee I've been watching you
forever, I'm just such a fan.
KANDEE JOHNSON: Thank you.
Thanks so much.
AUDIENCE: But you've shared
a lot of your personal life,
and the ups and downs.
How do you balance not sharing
too much, while also expressing
your true self to your fans?
KANDEE JOHNSON: It's really
hard, because in a way,
it feels like
everybody becomes so
much a source of
your friendship.
It feels like, oh, I could
share whatever I want.
And then sometimes you
realize you can't do that.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: You have
to protect yourself too, right?
KANDEE JOHNSON: Well there's a
lot of crazies on the internet.
Like I've had some
crazy stalkers.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:I think I
remember hearing that from you.
KANDEE JOHNSON: There's been
some really crazy evil ones.
Just things that you would
imagine like human beings
would do.
And so that's made me
a little more cautious
of-- like you do have
to do strategic things.
Like when you're at a
location, like I will never
post what hotel I'm
at, I will never
post where I'm at immediately,
because crazy people have
shown up.
And they're not
like, hey I love you,
it's like, (GROWING)
I love you, and I've
got a knife in my hand.
And it's just like, very scary.
So, there's just a
hard balance, and I
think some people use social
media as like a diary almost.
You can't do that,
because people would think
I'm schizophrenic if I was
like, I'm crying, and I'm sad.
And then a couple hours
later I'm good again.
And you're like, yay,
I love ice cream,
and they're like, you were just
crying an hour ago on Twitter,
what?
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
It's expounded
when you've got hundreds of
thousands, or millions of fans.
KANDEE JOHNSON: This morning.
I tweeted a thing.
I was just driving
by in New York.
And all these buildings.
There's a lot of
people in the city.
I can't believe there's
enough water for us all
to take a shower today.
It was a dumb thing.
Posted that on Facebook,
people went bananas.
They're like, how dare you?
People don't have water
in some countries,
and you're talking
about a shower?
And I was like, oh
my gosh, internet.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
It was just a comment.
KANDEE JOHNSON: I
can't say anything.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
What about you?
Do you kind of
feel like you have
to kind of put a little
bit of a barrier up?
Are you pretty--
MEGAN KROH: Oh yeah.
I've had some bad
times in the past.
I was working at-- before
I started YouTube-- well
actually, kind of when
I started YouTube,
I was working at a little place.
And people knew where
I worked, and they
were sending letters to my work.
And I didn't even know
about it, because my boss
kept the letters from me.
KANDEE JOHNSON: Letters to meet
you, or letters of meanness?
MEGAN KROH: Letters to me.
But I don't know what they said,
I never even looked at them.
She kept them from me.
But I realized that it was
my time to quit that job,
because it was just
getting too out of hand.
People recognized
where I was too--
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
Brought a lot
of business into
the store, probably.
MEGAN KROH: Probably,
but when I do vlogs,
like when I drive around
and do daily life videos,
I have to watch where I
am, and what I'm showing,
and so that's one thing that
I've learned over the years.
Be careful.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
That is a direct side
effect of having
everything in real time,
and posting so quickly around--
KANDEE JOHNSON: And
people care more about,
like a YouTuber feels like
a more intimate relationship
than with a celebrity,
where people
may be afraid to
go up to celebrity.
But we're more approachable.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: Very
accessible compared to--
KANDEE JOHNSON: So it's
a little different.
KANDEE JOHNSON: Where like if
Britney Spears is somewhere,
no one's going to bother her.
Or they're going to
be like (YELLING).
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: Most people.
KANDEE JOHNSON:
Which is awesome,
[INAUDIBLE] just the crazy ones.
I'll take a hug all day long,
as long as it's not a crazy,
want to kill you
hug or something.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
That's a good time
as for another question.
AUDIENCE: So hi, I'm Lena,
and I'm such a big fan.
I know I told you this, I
got a little bit starstruck.
I subscribe on my corporate
account, my personal account,
you have multiple subscribers
from this [INAUDIBLE].
KANDEE JOHNSON: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So my
question is, how do you
think of your long
term career goals?
What are they?
I'm curious to hear
from both of you
how you think of
progressing your brand,
and your presence in YouTube.
KANDEE JOHNSON: Oh,
that's a good one.
Because YouTube
is so interesting.
I mean, Justin Bieber
started on YouTube,
but Biebs isn't still
drumming on YouTube.
He went off to do things.
So there's like so many
things that I want to do.
And then after you've done
a tutorial on everything,
I'm like, how many more
contouring videos can I do?
Like I've already done
one, and three, and four.
So obviously, I would love
to do-- I want to do a book,
really explaining
makeup for women,
like in a regular-- maybe
it has waterproof pages,
you could take it
in the bathroom.
I don't know.
And then, I've always
wanted to do a makeup line,
and there's so many things
I want to go on to do,
that I mean, YouTube is amazing.
Like it's the biggest
blessing, that I never
even knew to ask for.
Because it's opened up-- I mean
Simon Cowell flew me to London
to work with him.
Like Simon Cowell, what?
That he knew that
I existed at all,
never would have happened
if it wasn't for YouTube.
So it's so amazing, I
had no idea any of this
would have ever happened when
I uploaded that first video,
you don't even see me in.
I was like--
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
And people see it.
I've seen it like, five times.
I'm like, wait, I've got to
make sure I'm doing this right.
What about you?
MEGAN KROH: I do want to
make my own makeup line.
And I also want to
make my own hairline,
because I love big Jersey hair.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: Your
hair is always gorgeous.
MEGAN KROH: Thank you you.
I don't care what anyone
says, I love my big hair.
I love big hair.
KANDEE JOHNSON: Big hair
never goes out of style.
MEGAN KROH: I love it.
And I love doing
my hair, so I feel
like a hair line would
be the best way to go.
And I've thought about
doing a makeup line too,
but that's what I
would love to do.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
I think you're
seeing a lot of businesses that
are growing outside of YouTube,
beyond YouTube, with
so many people who
started on the platform.
And I love the idea of books.
I think that's such an
interesting area that
is a little bit untapped.
You could even do an ebook.
You could do an
electronic book that you
could take in the bathroom,
and have your tablet.
KANDEE JOHNSON: Well
videos are great,
but sometimes you just
need-- like I just
need to look at a picture,
and read some steps.
I don't want to skim through
something a million times.
It's just maybe a lost art.
Like a book, a real page, weird.
It's kind of nice.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: Anybody
else have a question?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
First I want to say,
Kandee I love your message
about inner beauty, I thought
it was very inspirational,
but on top of the
external beauty,
I love both of your looks today.
So are these looks
that are specific looks
that are on your channels?
Or can you tell us
a little bit more
about the looks that
you went for today,
and what products you're
using, and what you did today?
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: We're going
to do a real time tutorial.
KANDEE JOHNSON: I'm going
to wash half of my face off,
and to the side.
Today, well, is a little fancy.
But I went crazy, and I
bought the YSL foundation,
and it's kind of like magic.
Like, you could have a
baby wipe on your face,
and you're like, you're
a makeup artist baby,
it just looks good.
It is so great.
And then I have
Cover FX concealer,
because if it can
hide a tattoo, it
is going to cover
any redness, or rings
anywhere up in this area.
And then, this just
all lots of lip liners.
Because they won't come off.
I think it's like,
"Embrace Me," from Mac.
Which I hope it's not
a discontinued thing,
that drives me nuts
when they to do that.
That and then I just
put a blush on top,
and it will make it matte,
and then it will last.
It almost lasted through
me eating my sandwich.
I think a little came off.
And then I just did
a black winged liner,
because that the fastest thing.
When you're in a
hurry, smokey eye
will take you too long,
blending for days.
I'm like, I don't have the
time for you, smokey eye.
You're just getting
a wing, and mascaras.
And then, I feel like
I'm so fancy today,
because I have the
Flutter lashes--
MEGAN KROH: There's
so many pretty.
KANDEE JOHNSON: They're amazing.
They're like $39.00 That
was the great [INAUDIBLE]
MEGAN KROH: What's
the brand of that?
KANDEE JOHNSON: They
just called Flutter.
MEGAN KROH: Oh, they're
I thought it was in a style.
KANDEE JOHNSON: The
Kim, or the Roxy.
I can't remember, but
they're like $39.00.
But you can wear
them for many times.
Just wash them.
MEGAN KROH: I know.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: That's one
though that I still can't get.
I've watched your application
video a million times.
I'm like, how does she do that?
KANDEE JOHNSON: Do
the demi wispies.
You cut-- when the
eyelash is curved--
cut that whole front off.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: And
just do it on the sides?
KANDEE JOHNSON: Well because
when you have a full strip,
it can look a
little stripper-ey.
Just to be honest.
But if you just do the demi
wispy on the outer part,
it doesn't look natural, but
it looks less stripper-ey.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
Well as long as you
get it on there straight, too.
KANDEE JOHNSON: I'm
like, half stripper.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: I
wipe my eyes all the time,
I'm scared it's
going to come off.
KANDEE JOHNSON: And it feels
like a seashell's on your eye.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
That's true, you
have to use the
sensation of wearing it.
I know that you also
have a video now,
with your new hair color.
KANDEE JOHNSON: Only a couple.
And I've seen a lot of hair
tutorials on your channel too.
MEGAN KROH: I'm
trying to do more.
I've got a lot of looks coming.
KANDEE JOHNSON: Well
hair is hard for people
too, because it's
again, something
that you don't learn how to do.
Like you don't naturally-- like
I know how to do beach waves.
It just doesn't come with
the curling iron you buy,
or flat iron you buy.
MEGAN KROH: Actually,
my look is the same
as that picture over there.
It's from my Valentine's
Day makeup look.
I've kind of been doing it every
day, I've been addicted to it,
using that chocolate bar
palette from Too Faced, two
actually smells like chocolate.
KANDEE JOHNSON: That is so
crazy that they do that.
MEGAN KROH: It's incredible.
So that's what I've been
obsessively with lately.
I mean I kind of went
a little full coverage,
I wanted to look
good for the camera.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: Your
lip gloss is beautiful.
Is that in the same palette?
MEGAN KROH: I'm
wearing the NYX butter
gloss, one of the new
ones, in fortune cookie.
KANDEE JOHNSON:It's just guru
makeup is named after edible
things.
MEGAN KROH: I love it.
KANDEE JOHNSON: Smells like
chocolate, tastes like cookies.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: Anybody
else have any questions?
AUDIENCE: So hey guys, I've
learned most of my makeup
from you two.
So thank you guys
for what you do.
It has saved me so many times.
But I noticed that
the more I start
to experiment with makeup, I've
kind of found this attitude of,
well there's the
guys who are like,
well I prefer my
women without makeup.
And then there's the women
who are kind of like,
well I don't wear any makeup,
so that makes me more special.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
The're an elitist quality
of the makeup-less woman.
AUDIENCE: There's
kind of this like,
well you're lying
because you wear makeup
on your face kind of attitude.
Or it's just because
you think you're ugly,
and you're not ugly.
Why do you feel the
need to wear it?
And I keep trying to
explain to people that it's
more I just like to do it,
and I like the way it looks.
So how do you guys
respond, when you
get those people who talk
about, you guys aren't real,
because you're hiding
what nature gave you.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:Or like
that superficial argument.
KANDEE JOHNSON: I just
reply with the same thing.
It's an art form, it's
a creative outlet.
Instead of a canvas,
you draw on your face.
And it's something that
you change everyday.
I'm not like, I can't leave
unless I contour my nose
to make it look different.
I'll do a wing up, I'll
put dots on my eyebrows.
I don't care.
It's like when you get dressed.
I'm not going to go
around and be like,
I am naked, because I'm not
covering up with clothes today.
I'm not going to do that.
It's just your style.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: That's a
really good argument, actually.
Well I don't walk around
with no clothes on.
KANDEE JOHNSON:
It's the same thing.
It's a way of
expressing your style.
Like I have friends
that are more pin-up.
They're more rockabilly.
And it reflects in
their makeup too.
And when I was younger, my
boyfriend would be like,
I love it that you
don't wear any makeup.
And I was like,
(SNICKERS), I totally
have mascara, and foundation,
and concealer, and powder
underneath, and you
don't even know.
Guys don't even know, really.
You're kind of safe that way.
MEGAN KROH: I would say
that if I wear makeup
because I love it,
and I feel confident.
It makes me feel
confident everyday.
I do struggle with acne
issues, and a lot of people
have said to me, I
can't believe that you
go on YouTube with no makeup on.
I can't believe you show
your face like that.
And sometimes it gets me down,
but the reason why I do it,
is because I want people to
know how to cover this up.
How to feel beautiful
with makeup on.
Because it makes
me feel confident,
and people actually have
searched how to cover up acne,
how do get a flawless,
full coverage face.
And I love it on myself.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: I think
that's really inspiring too,
actually.
Because I think a lot
of us see the images,
the airbrushed
images in magazines.
And you never think of Julia
Roberts as having dark spots,
or acne underneath her makeup.
And it's really inspiring to see
women where you see the after,
and you guys both
look beautiful.
I just learned how
to cover up my zits,
so hopefully they're
not all showing.
It's just nice to have, to
see that as a role model.
Especially for young girls
that are going through puberty,
and a time in their life
where they're breaking out,
to see that it's not all the
Julia Roberts airbrushed stuff.
That you kind of have
to go through a process
to get to that.
You don't just wake up in the
morning just looking like that.
KANDEE JOHNSON: Both sides OK.
I start my video off
without any makeup on.
People-- I always
go to the store,
and I don't have makeup on,
and somebody recognizes me,
I'm like, how did
you know it was me?
They're like, you
don't have makeup
on in the beginning
of your videos.
I'm like, oh yeah,
I forgot about that.
Why do I do this?
This is so weird.
But when you can see that I'm
OK with makeup on, it's fun,
and I'm OK without it.
And usually when you look
beautiful, and you're like,
I could see anybody.
And then you see no one, and
then you have no makeup on,
and you see ex boyfriends,
and all kinds of things.
You're like cool.
Today?
Great.
This is great.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
You have a question?
AUDIENCE: Hi guys.
Thank you for coming to Google.
KANDEE JOHNSON: Thanks
for having us here.
AUDIENCE: We love it.
So I have a couple questions.
The first is, at
what point did you
decide that you wanted to make
YouTube your full time job?
What was that day where
you were like, OK.
I'm going to do this,
and quit my other stuff
that I might be doing.
And then two, well I'll
ask the second one after,
if you don't mind.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: Number one.
KANDEE JOHNSON: That was when
YouTube became so-- for me, I
had a blog also, so it was
my blog, and my YouTube,
were taking up so
much time to do.
And then when I
realized, oh, you
can actually make
a living from this,
or from speaking at
events, or things
YouTube opened other
doors for, and that I
was making the
same amount as when
I was like trying to kill
myself getting a makeup job.
And I was like, hey, I'm working
harder, and longer hours than I
ever have, but I'm
making the same money,
and I don't have
to leave my house.
So I'll just do this.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: Was
there a tipping point video
for either of you?
Where it was just like you got
a ton of views on one video?
Or was it more like
a gradual process?
MEGAN KROH: I don't
think for me--
I don't know one of my videos
that really had a ton of views.
I can't really think of one.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: It just
kind of evolved gradually.
MEGAN KROH: Yeah, gradually.
KANDEE JOHNSON: I don't
think anything catapulted me.
I mean there was the YouTube
homepage, which I really
loved when there
was the home page.
Because that was like, when
you made it on the home page,
you're like, (GRUNTS)
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: Emotional.
Make it rain.
KANDEE JOHNSON: Hallelujah.
And again, I would only know
because I would get the most
evil comments ever when I
made it onto the homepage.
I'd just go to my
video, and it'd be like,
you suck, you should
die, you're so ugly,
you look like a man--
made it on the homepage!
So excited.
It was great.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: That's
all the 13-year-old boys
that accidentally clicked in.
KANDEE JOHNSON: Oh
yeah, I'm like, thanks.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: So did
you have a moment where
you realized-- outside
of the gradual process,
was there a moment
where you're like, OK,
I can do this full time now.
MEGAN KROH: I think
it was sort of when
I quit my other job that
I was talking about.
I realized that I was getting
a lot of positive feedback,
and a lot of people
were requesting things,
and I just realized
I was getting
a lot more views than expected.
I started this out as a
hobby, it was just a hobby.
I didn't even know you could
make money from it, at all.
The first time I realized
was when I got an email,
and they don't have this
now, because it changed.
But I got the email that I
was accepted for the YouTube
partnership.
The partner program.
I was amazed.
I was like, oh my gosh, I
can be a YouTube partner.
KANDEE JOHNSON: I didn't even
know you made money, either.
I just thought you had to make a
video longer than ten minutes--
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: I
think a lot of people
don't realize that.
KANDEE JOHNSON:
--Post up a thumbnail,
and an eleven minute video?
Yes.
MEGAN KROH: I was most excited
with when you became a YouTube
partner you could have a
banner, and you could do this,
and you could do that,
and you could decorate,
and I was so excited for that.
I didn't even know
about anything else.
KANDEE JOHNSON: I just wanted
the longer than ten minutes.
Because I'm like, how do
they get those twenty--
like twenty-seven minute video?
Oh, what I could
talk-- I couldn't even
make them that long.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: You
had another question too,
didn't you?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so then
another question is,
even though you're-- we
won't say the word "gurus,"
we'll say experts
for makeup and hair,
what brands who want to have
you maybe come and do a video
that's more lifestyle oriented?
That's not about your genre per
se, but more of you as a brand,
to talk about a family, or
just spring time, their summer
vacations, or whatever
topics that brands
might want to align with?
I'm curious about that.
Are you open to being
employed more in the lifestyle
way from a brand, instead of
always about your expertise
area?
KANDEE JOHNSON: Well I think
it's interesting, because once
you start on YouTube, I mean I
started so much about beauty.
But then people are like, oh
how do you make those cupcakes?
How'd you make your shirt?
Did you make your bracelet?
Where do you eat?
How do you workout?
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: What
Christmas gifts do you get?
KANDEE JOHNSON: How
do you wrap presents?
It became so much
more than just beauty,
which really amazed me at first.
And then, I just got to do
a commercial with Quaker
through YouTube.
And it was awesome,
because I mean,
I never felt like
a celebrity person,
and there was a star on the
trailer with my name on it.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
That's awesome.
KANDEE JOHNSON: And I was
like, and I don't have to film
or edit this?
I will do these every day.
This is so great.
And the oatmeal
tasted, good because we
had to keep eating it.
I'm like, thank goodness,
because if this was bad.
MEGAN KROH: I would say, since
I do have a vlog channel,
I mean that is my life.
I share my life, and what
goes on in my daily routine.
I share my family, so I
would say I'm open to it.
I share not just my
beauty advice, and tips,
but I also do share my life.
KANDEE JOHNSON: You
both have vlog channels.
Yours is--
KANDEE JOHNSON: I don't.
Kandeeland, which
I don't do a daily.
I don't know how
people do a daily.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: A daily
video on a second channel.
MEGAN KROH: I'm not up
to that daily [INAUDIBLE]
KANDEE JOHNSON: I can't.
The Shaytards amaze me.
They just amaze me.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: But
they have help, too.
They have people
KANDEE JOHNSON:
And he's editing.
We worked on something,
and in the breaks
when we weren't filming,
he's sitting on set.
always for the camera, editing.
And he'd hide his computer, it's
just amazing how they do that.
I was like, I would
just blow up if I
had to edit one
more minute a day.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
I think we have
time for one more question.
Anybody have the last question?
AUDIENCE: Why not have
someone help with editing?
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
The question is,
why not have someone
help with editing?
And I think a lot
of folks now, when
you get to a critical point
where it is a full time job,
a lot of people do hire you
know, a crew, or editors
or-- you guys are part
of the Maker network.
I don't know if you guys get
production help from them,
or if that's part of the--
KANDEE JOHNSON:
I think everybody
has different deals
with them, and I
think it's hard because a
tutorial, it's really hard.
Because how I film, I
don't think an editor
would know what
needed to be in there,
and I'd still have to go
in, and be like, no, no, no.
Show that a couple
seconds longer,
because the voice
over's got to be longer.
I think it's just hard.
And then when-- I don't know.
Like I edit weird.
I don't think I have the
most, like they're not
the most smooth,
professional videos.
I just funny things
in, or weird stuff.
And I think that's
what people like.
And if it wasn't that, if it
wasn't my fingerprint on it,
it would be not my voice.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
I totally hear that.
MEGAN KROH: I feel like it's--
I'm very picky with editing.
It has to go my way.
And I don't know.
I just feel very picky.
It's about-- well I
guess, it's about adding
your personal touch it.
The music you want, anything.
KANDEE JOHNSON: And I
think the more individual
you are as a person, the more
people know that that's you.
Where other people,
they wouldn't
know, because it's not so
much their personality coming
through.
But they would
know that it's not
one of my weird, quirky videos.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: Part
of it too, I'm sure,
it's like you guys started
doing this yourselves,
you've been doing it for
a long time, yourself.
And to kind of
hand that off, it's
like kind of handing
over your baby.
KANDEE JOHNSON: It is, you're
like, no I can't do it.
I would like help,
but I don't want it.
MEGAN KROH: It's really hard.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: Like I
need help, but I'm always busy.
KANDEE JOHNSON: But I
don't want your help.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: Any
last words of advice?
Something on your mind?
Trends, interesting stuff
that you're looking at?
Something you want to
impart to us here at Google?
KANDEE JOHNSON: I love Google.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: You should
come visit us more often.
KANDEE JOHNSON: If
it wasn't for Google,
I wouldn't be doing any
of this awesome stuff.
MEGAN KROH: Oh my gosh, me too.
KANDEE JOHNSON: I have this
shirt, I think it's awesome,
but it says the like,
"As seen on TV,"
but it's "As seen on YouTube."
It's my favorite shirt.
And I didn't ever think
it's a weird shirt
until you wear it out somewhere.
And then somebody will ask
about it, and they're like,
(DEEP VOICE) That's funny.
Where'd you buy that?
And I was like, well,
YouTube sent it to me.
And then it kind of begins
a whole weird conversation.
(DEEP VOICE) Well, like
why would YouTube send it?
Well I do tutorials
videos YouTube.
It's so awkward.
(DEEP VOICE) What do you do?
On YouTube?
You make money?
Is that what you do for a job?
It starts too many questions,
I'm like, I clean houses.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: Let's just
go rewind this conversation.
Cool.
Any last words?
MEGAN KROH: I can't
think of anything.
I really can't.
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
Well thank you
guys for coming, and sharing
your stories with us.
This is a departure from
some of the other talks
that we usually have.
KANDEE JOHNSON: Really?
STEPHANIE WENDELIN:
So it's nice to have
a little bit of nerd out
on the beauty category.
KANDEE JOHNSON: A little
beauty geek out, [INAUDIBLE].
STEPHANIE WENDELIN: Geek out.
We're geeking out
on beauty today.
Cool.
Well thank you.